[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight up here's welcome uncensored in
New York City is one of the most
controversial and popular commentators
in global politics a media Mogul
best-selling author hosted one of the
biggest podcasts on the planet is
influential he's intellectual it can be
inflammatory and tonight Ben Shapiro is
most definitely going to be uncensored
live from New York this is Morgan
uncensored
good evening live from New York City
Welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored from
the Big Apple these are incendiary times
in global politics debate has become
tribal Warfare we used to say that we
vehemently disagree we defend each
other's right to our opinions we're
going to have a drink or a cup of tea
and a laugh after sharing those opinions
but intelligent discussion has turned
into derangement our politics is
dangerously polarized it's no longer
okay to support or oppose Trump or
brexit without detesting shaming or
vilifying the people on the opposite
side of the argument taking offense has
become a full-time occupation and
there's currency and Clicks in being
outraged and perverse pleasure in
silencing censoring and shaming
especially if you deviate from the
radical woke agenda opposing Limitless
self-identity is apparently transphobic
debating immigration at all is bigotry
and racism defending the context of
history is also racist the world
ironically has become binary it's right
or left right or wrong good or evil
there's no room for nuance these are
dangerous times for democracies built on
free speech and free expression we'd
never be more inclined to miss anger and
hatred with one another on the basis of
our views alone and yet at the same time
we've never been so fragile so weak
doesn't take a genius to see that these
two things can't exist comfortably
together now I agree with my guest
tonight about I would say about 80 of
the stuff he says I passionately
disagree with the other 20 I suspect for
him the percentage might be higher on
the second part but Ben Shapiro and I
have clashed on air many times before
and I think we've come to a place now
where we have a better understanding of
each other it's not just about the
accents but whatever tonight is going to
be live and uncensored and it definitely
won't be dull
he's one of the biggest and most
controversial voices in American
politics Millions watch Ben Shapiro as
he skewers politicians and serves up
Savage tanks on the most incendiary
debates of the day he's the fast talking
host of one of the world's most
successful podcasts social relationships
that ought to be subsidized by
governments are the ones that produce
children and that would be man women
baby a former editor of the conservative
website Breitbart already a household
name by the first time he confronted me
you tend to demonize people who differ
from you politically by standing on the
graves of the children of Sandy Hook
I've seen you do it repeatedly Pierce
like I say how dare you but since then
this acid tongue debater has become a
world famous agitator created daily wire
a lightning rod platform for filming
stars like Candace Owens and Jordan
Peterson he's a best-selling author and
a thorn on the side of politicians on
the left and the right to his fans is a
Fearless Free Speech Champion to his
enemies is a dangerous Merchant of hate
you cut that out now or you'll go home
in an ambulance tonight fear Him or
Revere him he'll be here uncensored Ben
Shapiro
well that's quite an intro we've given
you and I appreciate it you better live
up to it well I mean I look at that old
tape and suddenly I hit puberty right we
both look so young oh my God uh I mean
that was what that's probably over 10 10
years ago right 10 years ago and it was
interesting because I was at the time
you know getting very angry about a
series of mass shootings in America with
a British sensibility and saying you
know obviously my country we don't
really have any guns and I was you know
hectoring and lecturing I guess
Americans about their gun laws and it
went down as badly as that phrase would
suggest particularly with with you but
what was interesting was when you came
on I thought who's this snotty little
kid who's going to start trying to take
me on and then it rapidly became clear
to me you were a hell of a lot smarter
than you appear
um so uh we've moved on from there
anyway we've had our kiss and makeup
interview after that but I I think what
was brilliant to me 2016. so seven years
ago now you tweeted a tweet this is your
pinned tweet to this date simply say
said facts don't care about your
feelings and if any phrase I think
perfectly epitomizes this woke era that
we have somehow stumbled into it's fat
because the woke Brigade put feelings
before facts
how do we get there well I mean and
culturally speaking I think that what
happened is that the value of subjective
authenticity became the core to pretty
much everybody so the the idea of
individualism was taken to its logical
extreme which was I'm so important and
everything I feel is so important that I
can ignore the rest of reality and in
fact reality is an imposition on me
institutions rules rules the rules of
the road all that sort of stuff it's an
imposition on who I truly am in order
for me to be actually free I have to
speak my truth now you know as I've said
and you've said there's no such thing as
my truth right there's your opinion and
then there's the truth but as soon as
you start speaking in terms of my truth
as soon as you start saying well there's
how I feel about the world and how I
feel about the rules is the core of me
what that also does it means that other
people are aggressing on you when they
disagree with you because obviously
assured reality means that we can
disagree about things out here but you
know we sort of as human beings are
intact but the moment that you start to
identify your truth with the truth then
anybody attacking your truth is
attacking you as a human being and I
think that that's where we've gone is is
this movement away from we're having a
political debate but again we can go out
and have a drink afterward because we we
are not the political debate the
political debate's a different thing to
my politics are who I am or my feelings
about who I am or my feelings about the
world that's the thing that matters more
than anything else and what's his
jewelry I mean I remember this we're
going to come to them later sadly but
Megan and Harry when they went on Oprah
Winfrey and she started talking
constantly about my truth and Oprah was
endorsing your truth and everything I
was like you I'm living in a sort of mad
world where
truth is no longer factual it's just
whatever you're feeling in any given
moment it seems such a perverse thing
for a Democratic Society that you move
away from fact based from science
whatever it may be to just feelings
dominating a culture and if you defy
those feelings you are instantly branded
the enemy and you must be destroyed well
there's no conversation to be had right
I can't have a conversation about your
feelings you're feeling your feelings
there's no way for me to dissuade you
from you can't deny my feeling correct I
can't say I can deny the facts that you
bring to the table but the problem is
once that becomes irrelevant then we're
just at an impasse there's no more
conversation to be had how big a problem
is it that at the same time
simultaneously I think you've had the
rise of very populist leaders like
Donald Trump Boris Johnson in the UK and
others who play pretty fast and loose
with the truth that you have people who
say well hang on you talk about the
sanctity of truth but you've got these
political leaders U.S presidents British
prime ministers where they don't seem to
care about matures they just bumble
through with whatever suits them from
day to day how dangerous is that to the
whole shebang I mean I think that that
is dangerous but it's dangerous in a
different way and it's also dangerous in
a more consistent and I would say
historically uh precedented way I mean
the fact is the politicians have always
fibbed to us I mean there's nothing new
about politicians saying things that are
not true from from LBJ to to George W
bush to to Donald Trump and Barack Obama
I mean like literally every politician
Joe Biden yeah right you see you see
this all the time so the idea of a
politician not telling the truth or
shading the truth in particular ways
that that's not what's new I think
what's new is where people are presented
with data and their immediate response
isn't let me bring you some data that
robots that data but I don't even have
to look at your data because your
motivation is bad right this philosophy
how dangerous is it though that we've
also become incredibly tribal I think
more than I can ever remember in modern
history actually you know when I read
your Twitter feed I think you're always
prepared to call out your own side if
you genuinely feel there's been some
egregious wrongdoing that they've done
or a terrible mistake or whatever but
the number of people prepared to do that
now on social media in particular is
minuscule most people Park themselves
into their tribe whatever that tribe may
be and there is no moving them there's
no deviation even if the facts change
and again it plays into well if your
feelings are the facts then if you feel
that fact is wrong well that's enough
right but the tribalism that I think has
has cropped up is rooted in a philosophy
called the motivism which is the idea
that everybody's actual viewpoints are
not driven by their view of the facts
it's driven by their internal emotions
what that allows me to do on the on the
converse is attribute malicious intent
to people that I'm arguing with and it
means that I get to ignore all of their
facts the reason that that I'm
disagreeing with you is because I'm good
and you're a bad person and what that
means is that people on my own side for
example they might be upset with me for
talking with people on the other side of
the aisle because why would you talk to
somebody who's a nasty person who has
bad motivations and the same thing on on
people on the other side talking to me
I've was having a conversation one time
with a very very large left-wing
podcaster this is probably 2018 and I
said you know we should really do like a
crossover podcast for the midterm
elections we'll do huge business and my
side will be totally fine with it it'll
be great and he said your site will be
fine with him my side will kill me right
and that that's probably that's the way
it's got on Bill Maher said to me you
know that comedy used to be rooted
really in right wing extremism being
comedic and that was the that was where
liberal Comics like him could get their
material now he said it's mainly to the
left it's the woke area of politics that
gives him the most comedic material and
he can't believe it as a liberal himself
he feels just really frustrated that
they don't understand how ridiculous and
laughable their positions on things have
become well it's it's driving a bunch of
people who consider themselves Center or
sensor left into the arms of people who
are more conservative actually I've made
the point before that I think the future
of the West May ride not on people who
agree with me most of the time you know
conservatives traditionalists I think
the future of the rest West might ride
on people who consider themselves kind
of traditional liberals who may agree
with some of the left's prescriptions
economically but who disagree with the
way they want to get there which is very
often by silencing debate using
censorship shutting things down so the
question is going to be are they willing
to put off Utopia for a while in order
to engage in the debates myself I've
always thought myself not really is a
political idea look right I I think I'm
pretty Centrist and call out everybody
really I'm more I see myself as a
journalist fundamentally and don't think
that being partisan helps that
particular profession very much as we've
seen from those who've as she drifted
down into being partisan as journalists
it doesn't work you become an activist
but someone said the other day you know
are you a conservative I said well I'd
never identified as a conservative but
the F the father lunatic that the left
woke go the more the pendulum swings and
eventually we all get sucked into
thinking well okay actually my
comparison to this I probably am getting
a bit conservative because I think
they're lunatics I think what's
happening right now and it's happening
in a bunch of countries is people are
just craving any sense of normality and
Common Sense and no one is providing it
to them right no one is providing to
them they're taking a a slap at the
people who are responsible for the
status quo as licensed to now do
whatever they want and so you're seeing
the pendulum swinging wildly side to
side because if you're a political
leader you're trying to harness the
passions of the moment to get done the
thing that you really really want to get
done when in reality the population just
wants things to kind of just stop just
alone and stop right I totally agree and
I think I think that's the majority of
people right I mean today Rolling Stone
uh published an opinion piece on why
cancel culture is good for democracy and
I read this piece and it was so
completely deluded because of course
cancel culture is the antithesis of a
democracy it's actually the antithesis
of liberalism you can't pretend to be
liberal with what that actually was
intended to mean and support cancel
culture I think I think the left uses
cancel culture in a very different way
than most of us use cancer culture when
we talk about cancer culture typically
what we mean is you say something that
they don't like on the air and they
decide to secondarily boycott your
advertisers or they go to your bosses
and call for you to be fired right and
that's what we mean by cancer culture
what they mean is well we're allowed to
disapprove of you well sure you're
allowed to disapprove turn the channel
right you don't have to subscribe why
you don't have to watch your show right
but what they do with that instead is
they attempt to get you kicked off the
air not by Dent of lack of ratings or
something but just because they're so
angry that they're going to go yell at
people and bother them until you get
kicked off the air that's that's what
cancel culture really is I interviewed
Congressman George Santos uh this week
who even by the
Staffing politicians I mean it was quite
startling I'll just play the clip where
he admits to being a terrible liar
I've been a terrible liar I mean would
you be prepared to say that sure like I
said well I've been a terrible liar on
those subjects
I mean this guy's a serving member of
the United States Congress right he's
one of the most powerful politicians in
the country by default and he just
admitted to being a terrible law whether
that meant does volume of lies or he's
very bad at them or in this case
uniquely but with both but what did you
make of that and should someone like him
be allowed to stay in congress I mean I
think that the voters are going to
decide whether he has to stay in
congress or not I don't have a lot of
standards for who gets kicked out of
Congress by members of their own party
because frankly I think that he's almost
the apotheosis of what politics to reach
which is I'm gonna lie as much as I can
get away with it and then the minute I
can't get away with it I'll just be like
well I'm sorry I lied I mean that's
that's a high profile Jewish man I want
to play the clip where he talks about
being Jewish well he separates the two
parts of the word let's have a look at
this
I would always say I'm I was raised
Catholic but I come from a Jewish family
so that makes me Jewish I said it's a
room with a thousand people in November
people were hysterically laughing it was
funny to them they loved it
now the people have already said they
were at that event and they weren't
laughing with him there's no sign that
of any evidence he has any Jewish
Heritage he claims his grandparents fled
the Holocaust there seems to be no
evidence for that it's Barons are both
from Brazil and this idea that somehow
he can be Jewish I not actually Jewish
just ish well I mean honestly what he
should have said is I just on the inside
I feel Jewish I feel so Jewish on the
inside so I'm Jewish I mean what are you
going to do challenge my feelings but he
has repeatedly said he's Jewish I mean
not he wasn't joking we've seen the clip
so he said it repeatedly yeah no again I
sort of see him as sort of he's almost
the apex predator of politicians at this
point he's reached he's reached the
logical endpoint of where our politics
is going and you know it is the job of
people like you or me to call it out
when when he says things that are not
true but I think that we've we have
reached a sort of post-truth era not in
that people don't pay attention to the
truth but I'm not even sure how many
people care about the truth now I do
think that can be exaggerated I do think
the bulk of the population really does
care very much about the truth and
that's why I think that it there's going
to be a tidal wave of resentment that is
about to crash across how important is
the truth to you because you've got this
huge following that massive podcast tens
of millions of people watching your
stuff on social media so on how
important is truth to you now that
everything comes out of your mouth or
that you write is fact I mean it's it's
the most important thing to me because I
have to sleep at night I mean it's it's
something that I try to think about as
much as humanly possible is is never lie
to your audience never say to your
audience a thing that you know to be not
true and try to follow this the best
data possible and that does mean that
you're very often having to be more
nuanced than sort of the politics of the
situation may allow because the easiest
position in politics is always to take
the the hardest right or the hardest
left position the sort of most pure most
easily understood position or to just
play the easiest game of all which is
again my opponent is a bad guy my
opponent is a person who hates it when
we had our desktop at CNN about gun
control for example I'm not going to go
over all that again but had I been very
different with if I'd been very like
respectful and said look I'm a British
guy these aren't my laws I'm just as
horrified As You Are by these massacres
and didn't talk about gun control which
I think has always been a terribly
inflammatory phrase for many Americans
they don't want to be controlled and the
second I want to hear a British accent
telling them about how they should be
more control but if I'd phrased it as
about gun safety if that had always been
the debate in America how do you make it
safer in a country that has 400 million
firearms and circulation would that have
been a more constructive debate do you
think I think it would have been a more
informative debate and the reason being
I think that Clarity is is very much
opposed sometimes by by Passion we
listen we all get passionate about these
issues I'm not going to pretend I'm not
passionate on my show or I'm completely
dispassionate in all circumstances I'm
obviously not um but you know I think
that that would have allowed for the
kind of discussion where we could have
looked at data from various areas of the
world where where have regulations been
effective or have they not been
effective what are as I said on the show
actually at the time I believe what are
the risks and rewards of particular
policies that's where the good
discussion area I think gets done have
you been just found a point on the gun
thing but it and I'm aware many viewers
who watch this in America own guns and
support yeah I own guns the Second
Amendment rights and so on
where do you see the the line going as
you have all these massacres and as gun
ownership increa increases there's more
guns in circulation
what do you do about that I mean as a as
a country as big and powerful as America
what more can be done to just make it
safer I mean again the measures that
I've always suggested are measures that
tend more toward the gun owner than
toward the the weapon itself meaning
that we obviously need better screening
procedures for people who have a history
of severe mental illness we have to we
have red flag laws on the books but
they're not enacted I mean people people
don't actually practically follow the
red flag laws which is why I'm kind of
skeptical of the idea that if we pass
some more texts from the legislature
that's magically going to translate into
into better action what we need is more
alacrity from the cops I mean how many
of these mass shootings have we seen
where there are a thousand red flags and
the cops go to the house and then
they're told well no we're not we're not
going to do anything we're going to
leave you back out there it's almost in
every circumstance so we actually do
need law enforcement to have more
ability and will to carry out for
example when they know somebody is
severely mentally Disturbed or somebody
is shooting a gun at their mother which
we have we've had a case like that that
would be a time where you actually
remove the person's guns and and keep
track of them make sure they can't
actually get guns right I mean see if I
buy again when I was doing that debating
I would have had this kind of
conversation I can look back at those
and realize I was adding my own emotions
over writing we all have these I mean
yeah but it's interesting isn't it I do
think an important part of how we get to
a better place as as Society now away
from this tribalism away from all this
stuff is you've got to be prepared to
have this kind of conversation which
doesn't end up with me just looking at
you and shouting well you're a complete
idiot because you don't agree with me
right
um it's more complicated it's more
nuanced life is more nuanced than that I
I like to think so and I think that
again those conversations can be really
really productive I try to make a habit
but I have my regular Daily Show but I
also have a show called the Sunday
special that you've been on in which I
bring on a bunch of people who disagree
from Bill Maher to Anna Hesperian and we
actually try to talk through these
issues and um I found a very
surprisingly pleasant experience yeah
exactly
let's take a short break I want to come
back and ask you that I mean the most
deadly question in the world right now
what is a woman
foreign
[Music]
Morgan interviews one of the most
controversial and influential voices in
American politics Ben Shapiro the lawyer
who took down a prince David boys Jordan
Peterson Superstar daughter Michaela
expect exclusives expect fireworks and
expect the unexpected
organ uncensored live from New York City
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel nobody
is uh every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what is a woman well I mean a woman is
whatever JK Rowling says a woman is and
she's right a woman is a biological
human female
how on Earth have we got to a place
where stating that simple fact has now
become a stick to beat people with when
from what I can ascertain 99 of the
entire planet agrees with that fact
again it goes back to that idea that
your subjective feeling about yourself
must be reflected by the rest of the
world cheered and celebrated by the rest
of the little because that's that's
actually what the ask is right the ask
isn't even you know I wish to be treated
well in society and you can think
whatever you want of me but you should
treat me decently that's not the actual
ass the actual ask is I wish for you to
participate in a delusion whereby I am a
biological human female or exactly the
same in many important respects as a
biological human female trans women are
women which again if you're refused to
find one about this and I've warned
about it and we've taken it to we've
said in the warnings if you take this to
a logical conclusion it's going to get
abused and we had a stark example of
this in Scotland several weeks ago with
this rapist Adam Graham who at his trial
having raped two women with his penis
and let's be great her penis well this
is the point he then turned up as Isla
Bryson and said I'm now a woman so
that's him before and then he comes
along as Isla Bryce there and the the
game plan according to his ex-wife is
what he just wants to get into a women's
prison which is obviously what his game
plan was and he got into one uh put into
a woman's prison where there are women
there who are vulnerable to attacks from
people like him
um that to me showed the insanity of
this we were a leader Nicholas sturgeon
been leader of Scotland for eight years
who supported this Limitless gender
identity nonsense and lost her job
actually I think it was a direct
consequence of this yeah I mean see what
she said I'll pledge you
the question is are all trans women
women they haven't answered that
question well that's not the point that
we're dealing with yeah trans women are
women but in the present context there
is no automatic right for a trans woman
there are context where our trans women
is not a woman no that is
there is circumstances in which a trans
woman will be housed in the male prison
estate
I think that interview Costa her job
because when I watched that it went on
for about 50 seconds it was jaw-dropping
because actually her ideology about this
was it was just cruelly exposed as being
completely ridiculous well it's an
Emperor's New Clothes kind of thing and
again when that happens to politicians
who are supposed to supposedly traffic
in fact it makes it very difficult for
them and so when you take a completely
logically unsustainable position like
trans women are women but some of those
women are going to be housed with the
man which is what she does In that clip
everybody can see how ridiculous it is
and it exposes the ideology for what it
is which is baseless and and nonsense
and and extraordinarily negative because
again if you undermine societal
perceptions of Truth we're supposed to
be living in this terrible time of
immisinformation and disinformation I
can't think of anything worse in terms
of misinformation than the idea that a
biological man is in fact a female and
when you see what's happening in sport
it's even more absurd where you see six
foot three inch swimmers formerly male
swimmers dominating the women's sport
and you think well where does this leave
woman sport if you just allow allow this
to continue ultimately women's sport
will get dismissed honestly the most
frightening part of this to me is not
even sort of the direct consequences of
this and some of it is directed at kids
right I mean we are teaching kids in the
United States who are five six seven
years old about gender fluidity about
how boys can become girls which kids are
vulnerable kids need to be protected
from nonsense and kids actually need
rules and expectations and and basically
saying to them that you can be a member
of the opposite sex is insane and what
we've seen predictably enough from young
people from teenagers is a radical
skyrocketing increasing rate of people
who are identifying as trans or gender
non-binary and then not shockingly at
the exact same time a rapid rise in
suicidal ideation and depression and
confusion none of that is a shock this
is all a social contagion there's never
been anything Scandal of the Tavistock
Clinic yes in London which you know
anyone who raised any concerns about
this was originally branded transphobic
which put people off raising concerns
but it turned out 97 of the young kids
that were sent there for this gender
reassignment turned out to have other
issues from autism to depression 97 and
what they really needed was an adult to
be adult about this and say well before
we irrevocably change
your body and cut you to pieces we're
actually going to have a proper
conversation about these other issues
you've got right exactly but but yeah
again I think this is part of a broader
attack on the notion of Truth and attack
on institutions is is really what it
what it is in the end because the
question is why is it so important to
teach kids who are five six seven years
old about being gender non-binary or or
trans again there is a natural condition
called gender dysphoria or gender
identity disorder and some people suffer
from it it's a very small percentage of
the population it is not 30 40 20 10 5
of the population but it does exist
obviously and those people are suffering
and we should try to find ways to to
help them whether that is in the medical
context with regard to therapy or
whether we're talking about you know
just families treating them well but
that that is not the same thing as
indoctrinating entire generations of
people and forcing all of society to go
along with it I mean this is the real
issue right you're asking all of society
to tell a lie in the name of sensitivity
well once you've done that with any
issue you can do that with pretty much
every issue well we saw it with the
ridiculous fast of the Roald Dahl but
all having this sensitivity reading yeah
removing hundreds and hundreds of words
and phrases from this from this you know
iconic authors through southern 300
million books suddenly they're rewriting
this stuff and some of the rewrites were
so completely ridiculous one where
attractors are referred to as black they
had to change that because somehow you
can't have a black tractor but what if
the tractor's black one of the real
problems here is that the modern context
cannot understand why kids would read
Roald Dahl that really is the major
issue right I re-rolled all my kids I
just got through I think pretty much his
entire corpus with my six-year-old and
extraordinary books kids love it because
the books are mean because the books are
yes right the books are about be life is
a rough place where people are mean to
you and social expectations are set for
you and people will talk to you which is
great preparation for what the actual
world is like correct words of them
whereas now you move to a place where
even egg and Spoon races have been
banned in England for example at schools
because they encourage too much
aggression amongst the kids who want to
win he's like well where does that leave
you then so kids get taught everybody
wins you will get a participation prize
once you have that mindset where's the
preparation for the real that's right
well it's a war against reality and the
reality is that for example in Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory being fat is
not as good for you as not being fat
right if you're Augustus Gloop it turns
out that you probably shouldn't overeat
but this is considered mean so we're
just going to cut the word fast but the
reader the sensitivity reader said it's
enormous right yes it couldn't be fat
but it could be enormous what are you
talking about you can't wipe that away
but again I think that's setting up a
predicate for a broader ideological
shift which is any problems you
experience in your life are through no
volition of your own or any action of
your own you're not responsible for your
own actions Society at large is
responsible for your actions for setting
up unrealistic standards of beauty or
Society is responsible for setting up
some sort of sensitivity to you as a
human being what about the damage it's
done for example I think a lot of damage
to being male being a man being
masculine that everything is now
characterized as toxic masculinity
absolutely I mean the the
effect on men and by the way by proxy on
women because it turns out that women
actually kind of like masculine medicine
all of human procreation is rooted in
this essential biological fact the the
destruction of men in the west is the
great story of the last 40 years which
is men basically
somehow got the paper the patriarchy was
so clever that they somehow convinced
women that sexual Liberation was
actually the most wonderful thing for
women but as it turns out it actually
backfired and it ended up destroying men
because men do need marriage men need
roles men need actual things to do in
the course of their lifetime and the
thing that most men did for virtually
all of human history was get married
have kids protect and defend your wife
and kids that was the rule and you were
trained to do this from the time that
you were a small kid it's what you know
I have three kids going on for I train
my kids to do this now I talk to them
about how many kids do you want to have
what kind of job do you want to have how
do you want to bring up those kids
they're small you train kids to be
adults because you know what kids want
they want to be adults and what they
want is a path from how I get to point a
being a child to being an adult but we
as a society have completely destroyed
that path because we've said that adult
Ting is now number one a verb and number
two we've said that being an adult is is
somehow no longer required of you
society's going to take care of you no
matter what problem you have it's it's
everybody else's job to fix all of them
people like Andrew Tate got such
traction yes so what I've said about
Andrew Tate is that I would say that 75
of Andrew Tate's diagnoses of the
problem are pretty correct yeah I agree
and then I would say that a lot of his
prescriptions are completely wrong yeah
right so so he will he will say men have
lost their role in the world and then
what he will model is cam girls it's
like well that's not actually the
solution but what you're saying about
the problem of men losing their role and
Men needing to be masculine and Men
needing to want to win and Men needing
to cultivate an ability to to go out and
succeed and thrive in the world all of
that is 100 true I just think that he
himself on a personal level wasn't
providing a model of that to me a model
of that is a guy who is married who has
kids who lives in the community who
betters the community lives in who hires
people creates a business like these are
the things that historically speaking
did Define manhood and now they no
longer Define manhood men I think that
you can shot at the moment of
deterioration for the moment James Bond
suddenly crying it's like you know you
take even that take even bonded
emasculating it's like he has to be in
touch with his feelings why why can't he
just shoot people and drink martinis and
seduce women and what's wrong with that
right well that is again a cultural move
and you're right against masculinity and
in pretty much every sphere and the
conflation of masculinity which is good
with toxic masculine that all
masculinity is bad so we need to
feminize Society overall we don't need
to feminize Society overall any more
than we need to masculinize society
overall what we need is for men to be
men and women to be women that doesn't
mean that women are barefoot and
pregnant in the kitchen as I've said
many times my wife is a doctor right
what it does mean is that there are
essential qualities to being a woman
that are different from many of the
essential qualities to being a man he's
not important here's one part of all
this debate which I disagree with you
about so you you don't agree with gay
marriage or with gay parenting I don't
want to miss quite yes I think that's
your position now I would say that
reading the rest of your views on stuff
you're very about fairness and equality
for all right how does that fit in there
why shouldn't two men who are gay
actually be able to bring a child up why
shouldn't they want to get married how
is it equal fair for them to be excluded
so we can take those issues one by one
so marriage is a societal institution
the question is which relationships
Society chooses to sanctify so I'm not
in favor of for example laws that
criminalize homosexual activity or two
men living together or two men making a
lifelong commitment to one another in
whatever context they wish to do that
what I'm objecting to is the idea that
marriage as a term is equally applicable
to relationships that are designed to
produce the future generation and then
raise them as opposed to two people who
love each other the fundamental
redefinition of marriage actually
happened before same-sex marriage within
heterosexual marriage away from the
purpose of heterosexual marriage is man
woman child to two people who love each
other once you do that then that
obviously is going to Encompass things
like two men or two women but it has no
limiting principle because then it could
be any group of people who love each
other and I don't think that the
government has a fundamental role in in
propagating relationships other than
ones that have externalities that that
benefit society and the chief
externality that benefit Society from
marriage is having children and children
raised largely with their biological
parents as far as gay parenting what
I've said is that they're sort of
hierarchies of options meaning that the
ideal is man woman child and then you
know if you can't fulfill that ideal
then there's obviously degradations I'd
rather that two gay men are raising a
child then have that child be in an
orphanage for example so it's not as
though the alternatives are always you
know the ones that I would want but
shouldn't they be allowed to have the
same just rights in law to what straight
couples would have well I mean it's more
benefits than rights right if you're
talking about it right what you're
talking about is a government
non-intervention with particular
activity now when it comes to children
we obviously do things to protect
children engaged parents who are
fantastic parents I've seen gay parents
where they are not fantastic parents
sure I've seen a lot of straight parents
who are awful and I've seen some great
straight Pro I don't really see any
particular distinction about what
combination you have as your past so I
do and the reason I do is because again
I think there is a fundamental
distinction between woman and man and
what that means is that mothers and
fathers are both necessary and so the
idea that two men can simply supplant a
man and a woman in a generic average
level I don't think what they're doing
they are this is what they I mean you
don't think that gay people become gay
presumably right well I mean I think
that the the notion that that everyone
who is gay was always gay from the time
that they were born I don't think that
the data back that per se because we are
seeing Rising levels for example across
Society of people identifying in a
particular way so there is some fluidity
to sexual behavior and sexual activity
there's less fluidity probably to sexual
orientation I assume that the majority
yeah sure gay people male and female are
born gay right if you take that as a
basic premise majority which I I
absolutely believe I'm just not sure how
it's fair or Equitable to deny them the
same rights to their relationship status
or to Parenting that you would give to
straight people so again I really don't
think that has anything to do with being
born or not born in a particular way I
think even if they were not born in a
particular way that the government
should not criminalize private activity
what I do think is that if we're talking
about the benefits that a government is
giving in order to propagate child
bearing and rearing within the context
of the biological parents which is again
what marriage originally was supposed to
be which is why marriage was government
sponsored what would you do if one of
you no idea but if one of your kids
turned out to be gay and wanted to get
married would you be tough on tough
enough to say you can't do that I mean I
would oppose that from so religion so
again marriage existence religious yeah
religion so so marriage exists in a
couple of different iterations one is
religious marriage which is kind of what
I care about and then there is
governmental sanctioned marriage which
is a public policy question right when
it comes to religious marriage no I I'm
not in favor of My Religion sanctifying
same-sex couple specifically because
again my religion propagates the idea
that man woman and child is the model
for families let's talk about a couple I
can talk to you about what the big
question of the Republicans Trump be
descendants what's going to happen who's
gonna win is Biden going to run again
and does age matter
[Music]
live from New York City Piers Morgan
interviews one of the most controversial
and influential voices in American
politics Ben Shapiro the lawyer who took
down a prince David Boyce Jordan
Peterson's Superstar daughter Michaela
expect exclusives expect fireworks and
expect the unexpected
sporgan uncensored live from New York
City
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel don't
worry every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
this is talk TV
back to Piers Morgan uncensored live
from New York City Ben Shapiro is still
with me live in uncensored he got a
fourth child coming along
congratulations thank you I have four as
well disturbing report in the New York
Post today that Peppa Pig is having an
uh well disturbing for you not for me
having a weird effect on American
children they're all beginning to speak
in English accents well has this
happened to you and how do you feel
about this I mean it hasn't happened to
me uh I I do feel like this is a
subversive British attempt to reverse
the results of the American Revolution
and this would be the second in in the
course of the last few years you sent us
Prince Harry apparently in an attempt to
conquer all and he and his and his wife
or she was going to become president
who's going to become first lady or
first general can you even imagine if
those two we're going to come to those
two in the last block because I can't
get there before then it's just too just
too distressing let's talk about
American politics um Trump V DeSantis is
interesting because Trump still Wills a
lot of power in the Republican party but
the scientist is pretty nearly the half
his age he's got all this dynamism now
very successful in the midterms really
doing a good job in Florida how do you
see this playing up because they've got
to work it out I think to have a success
in 2024. I'm not sure that they have to
work it out I don't think president
Trump is really capable of working it
out with people he sees as potential or
real Rivals to him that that's sort of
not his decision do you think yes and I
think the reason that DeSantis can beat
him is because Donald Trump is very
Charming when he's winning and when he
is losing he just seems whiny uh and
that's that's a real problem for him so
after 2020 when he maintained that he
won and he had not I think a lot of
Republicans were willing to Grant him
the premise which was okay you pulled
off this miracle in 2016 you're the only
man who can win so how could he possibly
lose in 2020 if you say you won okay
fine and then the 2021 elections happen
in Georgia and essentially he
contributes to the loss of two Senate
seats in Georgia and then the 2022
elections happen and pretty much all of
his hand-picked candidates in the Senate
then proceed to lose yeah and a lot of
Republicans look at this they say well
listen we have a lot of warm feelings
toward you personally but we can't keep
losing to these people and so we need
something new we need somebody who wins
and so when they look at the board the
person who's putting the most W's on the
board right now is to Sandston Florida I
mean the same election where Republicans
wildly underperformed there was a Red
Wave but it only hit one state it hit
the state where I happen to live in
Florida and it was 829 and I've been to
Florida a lot recently and they love him
in Florida oh yeah I mean you've got
Democrats who are voting for him and
independents who are voting for him he
took a state that they need one in 2018
by 0.4 percentage points and went up by
20 points in the last election cycle Joe
Biden If he if he runs again and wins he
would be 86 by the end of that term is
he I mean he's already the oldest
president in history and showing a lot
of signs of mental decline just be kind
about him and he fell over on the plane
again today oh we got that that clip but
it's just when you see these moments I
think we've got to hear
um this is him in Europe it is hard to
watch because this happens quite
regularly and it happens not just
physical stumbles it's verbal as well
would you think he's going to run again
yes I think they will have to staple him
upright on a horse and they will because
I I don't think that they want the
internation Warfare have a bunch of also
rounds I mean backing him up is the
worst politician ever cobbled together
from the laboratory I mean she is awful
I mean she makes Hillary Clinton look
like the apotheosis of charm and she's
she's backing him up and then you have
Pete butterjudge who is busily
destroying his own reputation over the
seas Palestine train spill I mean I
could not go down there for three it's
just absolutely blessing so Donald Trump
has gone down there today just to do you
know be the hero you think where is the
transport secretary especially if you
have presidential aspirations the way
that I'm planning on going well when
right it's not that hard I mean you just
just go yes but get on a plane and you
turn up and you you know it's always a
bad time when you know the name of the
transportation secretary right there are
certain departments in the government
where you just don't know anybody's name
transportation is one of them but after
presiding over the supply chain problems
and then the Railroad Strike and then
the the East Palestine issue and the
airlines I mean he's had a bad run here
and so if you're the Democratic party
and you're looking at the next batch of
people I think he's done himself in it I
think they've got a real problem on
their hands
for the right thing to do Nikki Haley
has put a hat in the ring and was
immediately uh the victim of an
extraordinary Onslaught from Don Lemon
who happened to take my old office at
CNN actually not that I hold a torch to
that obviously but here's the clip of
what Don Lemon said about Nikki who's 51
years old
Nikki Haley is in a prime sorry when a
woman is considered being a prime in her
20s and 30s and maybe 40s that's not
according to me Prime for what it
depends I mean it's just like Prime if
you look it up it'll if you look if you
Google when is a woman in her prime
it'll say 20s 30s and 40s
imagine two women either side of you and
we'll see a name of people like
Christian I'm on board all these great
journalists all by his yardstick way
past that Prime now I mean just the
crassness of it well I mean I do love
the gay man explaining to the two women
what a woman in her prime
and he Googled it he Googled it he had
to Google it so there there was that but
yeah it's it what is amazing about this
and sort of a broader trend is the
amount of hatred that Haley is picking
up from the left side of the media which
I think is a tell so the media have said
for years and years and years that they
want Trump out Trump has to go he's a
fascist threat to the United States and
then the minute that a candidate throws
her hat in the ring against Trump she's
the first declared candidate against
Trump and the minute that happens all of
a sudden she right she said she said
okay and she's two and she's too old for
the job at 51 and all which suggests to
me that a lot of these people have been
you know crying into their into their
soup a little bit over over Donald Trump
they really want him do you think
ultimately the race will be DeSantis
against Biden I think that that's the
highest likelihood and you think who
wins that I think the chances wins that
race yeah I I think that that Biden's
been cruising for a bruising and he
narrowly avoided in 2020 because the
Republicans decided to raid the local
homeless shelter for candidates
let's come back uh we're gonna finally
get to them Harry and Megan and the
South Park devastating construction of
everything they represent we want our
privacy
I wish the whole world's been chuckling
over we're talking about that out of the
brain
thank you
[Music]
live from New York City Piers Morgan
interviews one of the most controversial
and influential voices in American
politics Ben Shapiro the lawyer who took
down a prince David Boyce Jordan
Peterson Superstar daughter Michaela
expect exclusives expect fireworks and
expect the unexpected
organ uncensored live from New York City
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel note
what are you uh every little helps for
God's sake is nothing original anymore
it's finger licking Goods I'm loving it
look let's be honest we don't have any
fancy speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
foreign
[Music]
's lawyers vow her battle to return home
is nowhere near over after a judge
throws out her bid for UK citizenship
and Tony Blair pushes for the government
to introduce digital ID cards in a plan
some have branded creepy and World War
who a third of Brits have no idea
Winston Churchill was our wartime prime
minister that's all coming up at nine
foreign
live from New York Ben Shapiro stay with
me so we've got to get to them uh Harry
and Megan unfortunately let's take a
look at the South part just because it
makes me how I would laugh every time I
look at it
it has been several months now since
I've been Queen has died our Canadians
are finding it hard to go
oh Canadians that is except for our
first Guest The Prince and his wife
foreign
thanks for having us on the show
in a way these two absolutely personify
woke culture don't they the entitlement
The Virtue signaling the hypocrisy all
of it is encapsulated in these two and
the untouchability right if I mean you
found out right if you say something
that crosses them yes you hurt their
feelings and they're very and they
believe they have a right to get people
removed from their jobs if they don't
agree with everything they're saying
well and I think it's a lie I think the
public reaction to them is so heartening
because they really are quite terrible I
mean I'm watching this as an American I
have no dog in this particular fight but
I gotta say they're just they're just
the worst and the the I actually read
Prince Harry's awful Memoir and uh the
the number of things that are obviously
not true yeah and the absolute
self-delusion and arrogant self-delusion
intrusion into his own family's life
quoting family members from funerals and
stuff far more interesting he wants
privacy but he has very specific
memories of using particular facial
cream on I didn't know we're taught I
mean I'm American we don't use the word
Dodger in my country so I have no idea
what I mean now I know but you know
everything what happens to them now I
mean they've done all this stuff Netflix
but it's all basically their entire
value is predicated on trashing the
family and the monarchy there's a that's
a diminishing returns right yeah I mean
I I don't think there's a Next Step here
I mean once you actually destroy your
source of value which is the inside view
of the monarchy and you've already
spilled that what else is there to do
other than stand outside and just shout
a lot and then as South Park implies so
Americans I mean do is there any love
for them here or not I mean I'm
searching for it now ridiculed because I
think it's all ridicule at this point
I want to talk about a chat GPT which I
don't know much about other than it's a
bit worrying when we asked them to write
a tweet in my style and they came back
with I'm tired of these PC snowflakes
trying to dictate what I can and can't
say freedom of speeches under attack
hashtag wake up which is pretty damn
accurate so I I interview Professor
Stephen Hawking before he died last TV
interview he ever gave an amazing day we
did up in Cambridge I said what's the
biggest threat to mankind he said when
AI learns to self-design that's it are
we getting anywhere near now I mean it
certainly feels like we are approaching
it and this is just the the latest
iteration of US unleashing forces that
we have no idea the consequences should
we be unleashing them uh I I have some
serious doubts about whether we should
be unleashing them at least in this sort
of uncontrolled fashion that we're
seeing right now I'm not sure the
government is capable of controlling any
of this sort of stuff the thing honestly
that I'm most worried about is when you
combine the rise of Internet pornography
with the rise of Chachi PT which is
going to I think play on the emotions of
people using the internet I mean we
could be one generation away from from
human extinction at this point I mean if
you look at the actual rates of
propagation in the west and you look at
the rates of dating and the rates of
marriage like all that stuff is taking a
mass dive and you know I'm pretty
worried about that so apart from the
imminent end of the entire planet is
there anything positive you can give
well I mean the good news is that you
think about the world what do you feel
good about my good news is is twofold
one is that the era of anglo-american
dominance is not yet over right what
we're seeing in Ukraine is actually
rather heartening because it suggests
that the post-world War II system is not
yet dead so that's a good thing and and
the other thing that I think that that
is good is that I root for reality
reality always wins and so all of these
kind of forces that we've Unleashed they
are running up directly against the
rocks of reality and there will be
Concepts you feel the woke worm is
turning because I do I feel that the
backlash against wokery is now real and
people have basically now said enough I
think that's right and I think what's
even more heartening is that the people
who are pushing it don't realize that
yet right so they're going to continue
to push right into the teeth of the
resistance and when that when when the
draw is clamp shut it's going to get
very ugly for them I think you've made a
business now which is generating
hundreds of millions of dollars in
Revenue extraordinary story probably all
down to the way you chewed me up on CNL
there's years ago things have worked out
quite well for me too so happy days but
it's an amazing business
um why do you think you've resonated
so hugely not just in America but in
around the world again I think that the
central brand which is that we are very
honest about where we are coming from so
we're honest about our own political
biases but we're also trying to be as
factual as humanly possible and we do
provide a wide variety of views I mean
all of our hosts disagree with one
another Candace disagrees with me
disagrees with me that's the power of
your brand is I really do I think it's
and that's what I try to inspire to be
myself you've got to be fair-minded
about it right I mean hopefully if
you're opening up that conversation then
people are going to learn more than they
than they came in with I think today
they will Ben Shapiro great to see you
great to see you all the best that's it
from me uh I'll be talking exclusively
to the YouTube mega star term boxer Jake
Paul and the former British prime
minister Gordon Brown about Ukraine
whatever up to Keep It Uncensored that's
it from me live in New York we're gonna
go and get a drink aren't we
chew the fat
[Music]
thank you
live from New York City Piers Morgan
interviews one of the most controversial
and influential voices in American
politics Ben Shapiro the lawyer who took
down a prince David Boyce Jordan
Peterson Superstar daughter Michaela
expect exclusives expect fireworks and
expect the unexpected
this organ uncensored live from New York
City
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it